what would you think you'd do work at a
carnival you look good in lipstick so
thank you
um I look at anything
um what would I I don't know I mean
you're not building robots I mean you
could have been a Tesla right okay I
didn't mean a car I meant the person
like I understand oh thank you for
explaining the way he comments to me I
didn't I didn't at all because you
wouldn't do an Einstein because your
name he was an immigrant so I wouldn't
work with the name again what does that
even mean no you would have been a Tesla
like figure there's already a Tesla so
you wouldn't literally be Tesla that's
why I said a Tesla oh ah Tesla okay so
all right thank you for the explanation
see Mike Michael doesn't only make funny
things he also explains them for you it
wasn't fun it wasn't funny at all that I
agree with okay
okay so yes when when you achieve see
this is why Kanye didn't like you it's
this
all right I'm I'm downgrading it from a
nine down to an eight
and if you keep talking like this
uh a five is a real possibility